revisemos lo que hicimos en el vídeo
anterior ya que todo esto puede ser un
poco complicado y confuso así que no nos
va a hacer daño revisarlo una segunda
vez y más adelante hablaremos un poco
sobre cómo estas dinámicas se pueden
modificar para evitar que el yuan
aumente de valor en el vídeo anterior
comenzamos con un cambio de divisas de
10 yuanes igual a un dólar vimos que
este fabricante de acá en china tiene
que vender sus productos a 10 yuanes
para que él pueda obtener una ganancia y
el fabricante en eeuu tiene que vender
sus productos en china por el
equivalente a un dólar en este precio de
cambio de divisas 10 yuanes son igual a
un dólar estadounidense y en este caso
este vendedor tiene que vender su soda
por 10 yuanes para obtener su dólar
aquí abajo no dibujamos ilustrando el
intercambio con este precio estas
muñecas a 10 yuanes tener una demanda de
100 unidades en eeuu y en china por la
soda a un dólar había una demanda de 50
unidades y vimos esta dinámica de que se
enviaban estas 100 muñecas a eeuu y de
eeuu se regresaban 100 dólares ya que
cada muñeca cuesta un dólar en el otro
lado de la ecuación el fabricante de la
soda vende cada soda a 10 yuanes y hay
demanda de 50 latas en china así que él
enviará a 50 latas de soda a china y
ellos le regresarán 10 yuanes por cada
lata o sea va a recibir 500 yuanes lo
que sucede en esta situación es que el
fabricante chino va a tener mil yuanes
que necesita convertir a dólares de
preferencia en 100 dólares si es que esa
tasa de intercambio estuviera fija el
fabricante de eeuu imaginemos que estas
son las únicas dos empresas que tienen
un intercambio internacional
este fabricante tiene 500 yuanes que
tiene que convertir a 50 dólares
aquí tenemos una persona que necesita
convertir en mil yuanes los 100 dólares
que recibió de sus ventas si es que el
cambio de divisas se mantuviera
constante pero sólo hay 500 yuanes
ofertados en el mercado así que aquí
tendrán que ofertar semas dólares por
yuan que si hubieran más yuanes en el
mercado ahora si vemos este otro lado el
fabricante estadounidense tiene 500
yuanes por sus ventas en china y los
tendría que convertir si es que el
cambio de divisas estuviera constante a
50 dólares pero podrían hacer una
cantidad mejor que esos 50 dólares como
podemos ver hay más demanda para
convertir los yuanes que para convertir
los dólares
él quiere comprar 50 dólares usando los
yuanes y esta persona quiere vender 100
dólares para convertirlos en yuanes si
vemos por acá el suministro de dólares
es mucho mayor que la demanda
la demanda de dólares y ustedes saben
que si la oferta o el suministro de algo
es mayor que la demanda por ejemplo si
hubiera más oferta de manzanas o
suministro de manzanas y la demanda
fuera menor pues el precio de las
manzanas caería y aquí sucede lo opuesto
con el yuan la demanda del yuan es mucho
mayor que la oferta o el suministro de
yuan y cuando esto sucede nosotros
sabemos que el precio va a aumentar así
que aquí estamos viendo el escenario en
el que el precio del dólar baja con
respecto al yuan y eso significa que si
yo tuviera que dar diez dólares por
johann ahora tendría que dar menos
yuanes por ese dólar si el precio de las
manzanas en yuanes disminuyera en lugar
de ofrecer 10 yuanes por manzana se
darían 8 yuanes por manzana aquí vemos
exactamente lo mismo para el precio del
dólar es lo equivalente a decir que el
precio del yuan aumenta eventualmente y
aquí estoy inventando las cifras para
predecir cómo va a quedar el precio al
final llegan eventualmente a 8 yuanes
por dólar
dijimos que con este valor de
intercambio a 8 yuanes por dólar
esas muñecas de 10 yuanes ahora costaría
1.25 dólares y digamos que esas muñecas
a 125 de dólar tendría una demanda de 60
muñecas
aquí estoy modificando las cantidades
del vídeo anterior para que quede un
poco mejor en los cálculos
y recuerden cuando las muñecas que
valían 10 yuanes estaban a un dólar la
vieja demanda de muñecas era de 100
unidades y ahora que aumentó el precio
pues la demanda ha disminuido lo que
tiene sentido ya que si las muñecas
valían un dólar pues las personas
podrían comprar más de estas si el
precio de esas muñecas aumenta a un
dólar con 25 centavos la demanda va a
disminuir en este caso disminuirá a 60
muñecas el otro lado de la ecuación la
lata de soda de un dólar a 8 yuanes por
dólar se va a vender a 8 yuanes y
recordemos que el precio anterior de
esta lata de soda en china era de 10
yuanes así que el precio de la soda pasó
de 10 yuanes a 8 yuanes se abarató así
que ahora hay más demanda por esta zona
así que cambiamos esta cantidad también
ignoramos este número y ahora digamos
que la demanda en china pasó de 50 latas
que teníamos aquí donde se enviaban 50
latas de eeuu a china a 10 yuanes por
lata
y pasamos la demanda de 50 hacia 75
lacas y estoy inventando estas
cantidades porque nos va a llevar a
cálculos más sencillos y ahora cuál
sería el nuevo escenario y usamos estas
cantidades porque me da la impresión de
que mientras más concretos sean nuestros
ejemplos
ustedes los comprenderán mejor y ahora
cuál será el balance comercial entre
china y eeuu aquí ponemos en un lado
chino y aquí en el otro lado eeuu bueno
de este lado desde china sólo vamos a
estar enviando 60 muñecas y los eeuu
estarán enviando 60 por 1.25 dólares
serán 75 dólares 1.25 por 60 es igual a
75 dólares así que 75 dólares irán de
regreso china eso es en el caso de las
muñecas ahora veamos qué pasa con las
latas de soda vamos a enviar 75 latas de
soda de eeuu a china y desde china van a
enviar de regreso 75 por 88 yuanes por
lata van a ser 600 yuanes
así que va de regreso de chino de eeuu
600 yuanes y ahora qué va a suceder el
fabricante chino que está de este lado
izquierdo quiere convertir 75 dólares
en 600 yuanes
ya que ahora suponemos que el cambio de
divisas está a 8 yuanes por dólar va a
necesitar convertirlos a 600 yuanes 75
por 8 es igual a 600 y el fabricante en
eeuu quiere convertir 600 yuanes en 75
dólares sus 600 yuanes de la venta de
las sodas y suponiendo que quiere
convertirlo usando el precio de divisas
actual 600 dividido entre 8 va a ser
igual a 75 dólares qué es lo que sucede
aquí la oferta o suministro de dólares
es igual a la demanda de dólares de este
otro lado y también la oferta o
suministro de yuanes es igual a la
demanda de ayuda desde este otro lado
así que ahora dependiendo de ustedes
cómo lo vean se envía el mismo valor de
dólares de los eeuu hacia china y lo
mismo se recibe de china por lo que el
valor de las divisas ahora se encuentra
en equilibrio y es por eso que quería
revisar de nuevo este problema para
mostrarles que cuando se tiene una
dinámica de divisas libre
un equilibrio en el mercado una divisa
se volverá más cara que la otra pero la
demanda las va a equilibrar por lo que
al final
eventualmente se tendrá un equilibrio de
divisas espero que esto no los haya
confundido demasiado y en el siguiente
vídeo veremos cómo el gobierno en
particular el banco central chino puede
intervenir de manera que esto no suceda
de manera que siempre puedan enviar más
hacia eeuu de lo que eeuu les envía a
ellos